الجزء الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله كشف مسؤولون امريكيون الجزيره
عن ان البيت الابيض حسنا قرره بتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز وان الاعلان
الرسميه سيكون واليوم الاربعاء ونقلت
وكاله سوشيت برس عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
العمل سيتواصلوا على صفقه الدبابات ابرامز
لاوكرانيا وسيتم شراءها ضمن مساعدتنا
امنيه قادمه
وبالتزامن مع ذلك هكذا وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه
وكانت صحيفه مديرش فيجل قد نقلت عن مصادر
قول هاي المانيا ستسمح كذلك لبلدان الاخرى
مثل بولندا باعاده تصدير الدبابات
وقد حذر المتحدث باسم الكريم للناديمتري
بيسكوف خلال مؤتمر الصحفي من ان تسليما
كيف دبابات البارده سيتركوا اثرا لا يمحى
على العلاقات مع بيرلين وقال بيسكوف ان
عمليات التسليم هذا لن تاتي باي خير عن
العلاقات بين روسيا والمانيا مستقبلا
نقلت تلفزيون التركي وعما سماها مصادر
الدبلوماسيه تركيه ان الاجتماع الخاصه
المتعلقه بمسره انضمام الاخرتين الى حل في
شمال الاطلسي قد تم تاجيله يذكر ان
الاجتماع الخاصه بهذه المفاوضات كان من
المقرر عقده في بروكسل في شهر فبراير شباب
المقبل
وقد اكد رئيس الوزراء السويدي
رغبه بلاده في العوده الى الحوار مع تركيا
واضاف كريسترسون انه اذا لم يكن هناك حوار
فعال فسيكون صعبا على السويد الانضمام
وهذا ستكون له تداعيات على منها
من جانبها وزير الخارجيه الفنلندي لا
ضروره ان تدرس
من دون السويد
من جهته يقلل متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نيت برايس ان بلاده ترغب في
استمرار المحادثات بين السويد وفنلندا
وتركيا بشان الانضمام الى حلف النيه هو 10
الى ان ستوكهولم وهلسنكي اتخذتها جميع
الاجراءات للوفاء بتعهداتهما ضمن مذكره
التفاهم المشتركه مع انقره
قال بيان صادر عن الديوان الملكي الاردني
ان الملك عبد الله الثاني شدد خلال لقاء
ان جماعه في عمان مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو على ضروره
احترام الوضع التاريخي والقانوني القائم
في الحرم القدسي الشريف بينما نقلته السيد
الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان نتناه تعهد خلال
اللقاء بالحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي
والقانوني للاقصى ياتي هذا بينما دعى
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
اسرائيل الى الامتناع عن اي اجراءات
احاديه قد تقوي تحل الدولتين بما في ذلك
مصادرات الاراضي وبناء المستوطنات وهدم
المنازل
انتهى الموجز انا كنت مرتبط اوقاتكم بكل
خير
[موسيقى]